uh welcome to hannity we are tracking
multiple major stories that will impact
your life
including the shocking scene from new
york city
look at this friday night 11 30 a.m
broad daylight the streets of new york
city
that man right there beaten slashed
robbed by a group of 12 people now make
no mistake violent crime is now
spiraling out of control in many of
america's major cities
yep it was back to rioting in portland
seattle and denver last week
now this is what defunding the police
and helping people arrested get
free bail kamala harris and
not speaking out and calling riots
riots like last summer this is what it
looks like
more scary times we'll have a lot more
tonight also nancy pelosi's
prayerful and solemn duty radical
extremists
to smear the president even out of
office for all eternity has now
officially reached the senate coming up
we'll have the very latest details from
the democrats unconstitutional
post-presidential impeachment charade uh
by the way which is falling apart it is
now officially blowing up in the faces
of biden and every other democrat in the
swamp
senators by the way republicans rubio
cornyn
cotton all now forcefully speaking out
against the
impeachment as of today it's a foregone
conclusion there will not be
a conviction but an acquittal everyone
knows the trial is dead on arrival
get this chief justice john roberts
rightly now refusing to preside
over the trial the later shift show and
of course if biden really cared about
unity uh he could put a stop to the
shift show right now
so much for that unity bs words no
meaning
just you know smoke and mirrors
obviously it doesn't care about unity at
all whatsoever
he's out of office aren't you happy all
right
now by the way that is why the first 24
36 well 24 now executive orders take a
look at this it reads like a wish list
for the radical extreme socialist base
they're the ones in charge
and biden is now halting all border wall
construction he's stopping all
deportations
amnesty is on the way he's incorporating
illegal immigrants into the u.s senate's
census and pausing student loan payments
and of course he's
waging a war on american oil and gas
and this has real consequences for real
people our friends our neighbors
thousands of people now being laid off
because of
biden's cancellation of the keystone xl
pipeline
the biden obama administration remember
they in their years
four years ago plus had predicted 2
billion in wages
if the pipeline was ever built but they
never lifted a finger
donald trump got that done and now
biden's radical agenda
is literally taking thousands of
american jobs
hurting american families all while
economic stress
is the norm for way too many of our
fellow americans
because of covet and of course the
subsequent oppressive lockdowns
we're going to hear from one of those
workers a fellow american in just a
moment
what's his life like now and with the
stroke of a pen
this guy lost his job so to joe's
fawning fans and big tech the media mob
this is why yes i'm critical now
this early of the biden administration
this is why i rightly
called his first week in office a
pending disaster
the mob saying had and he's he's already
saying
that joe's failing well these policies
will always fail why i have chapter four
my book live free or die
america and the world on the brink
actually has a whole chapter in there
that says socialism and its history of
failure
it will fail again this is why we will
continue to vet
joe biden in all of his policies 99
so-called journalists in this country
they're now on
well we'll call it a sycophantic
vacation
so per usual we end up doing their jobs
for them all
and at the same time we'll continue to
fight back against canceled culture
it is now worse than ever more
oppressive than ever more chilling than
ever
it's an embrace of authoritarianism and
some other left are calling on the
government to censor
regulate freedom of speech in other
words
speech they don't like or agree with and
some even
on so-called news networks fake news cnn
msdnc they want fox news
ripped off the airways they want this
show canceled talk about cancel culture
they have the biggest propagandists they
themselves they're the biggest purveyors
of lies hatred in the country i have
five years worth of never-ending
material
others have continuously and
enthusiastically you know praised big
tech censorship of conservatives
and of course their censorship of real
stories in the lead-up to the election
senator josh hawley he had a book deal
canceled they actually wanted to use the
14th amendment to remove him and
ted cruz for daring to ask for an audit
of election well sorry if you disagree
but that's what this country was built
on all because they supported yes a
10-day
audit of our election results something
democrats in the past have done
in an op-ed new york post senator hawley
encouraged all americans to take
a stand against this muzzling of america
senator hawley will join us in just a
moment first we begin this monday night
we turn our attention to the biden
administration's ongoing quote
efforts against covet 19. remember it
was just a few months ago
when then candidate biden frequently
used the pandemic
to bash president trump in one of his
rare appearances in fact
he personally blamed the president
pretty much for every cove of death not
china
no the dog bites the bee stings you're
feeling sad there's only one person on
this earth to blame
donald trump take a look if he if the
president had done his job
had done his job from the beginning all
the people would still be alive
all the people i'm not making this up
just look at the data
look at the data look at the data okay
joe and kamala claim they had a plan to
beat covert 19 they vowed to quote
get the virus under control deliver
immediate relief to working families
apparently
that's not the case look at this joe
guess what
now there's nothing he can really do to
change the trajectory of the pandemic
that's not what he was saying in the
campaign at all take a look
if we fail to act there will be a wave
of evictions and foreclosures in the
coming months
as this pandemic rages on because
there's nothing we can do to change the
trajectory of the pandemic
in the next several months now keep in
mind multiple vaccines have already been
deployed thanks to donald trump and
by the way around a million doses are
being distributed
and being put in people's arms every
single day just like during the trump
administration
and remember those international travel
bans president trump
implemented well actually in about six
days
exactly one year ago to stop the spread
of coven 19.
now the biden administration they
themselves are extending
the travel restrictions but you remember
after the president implemented that
uh yes last year about a year ago on the
campaign trail
there was joe out there tweeting that
the travel ban was hysteria xenophobic
and
fear-mongering and again in march biden
again
called the coven 19 travel restrictions
restrictions
xenophobic fear-mongering well i guess
that makes
joe biden xenophobic and a fear mongerer
our own peter ducey asked biden's press
secretary about this and as per usual
the answer well misleading
when president trump was imposing travel
restrictions in march specifically
on china then candidate biden
called it xenophobic and fear-mongering
so
now president biden is putting travel
restrictions on people coming in from
other countries
what words we use to describe that well
i don't think that's quite a fair
articulation
uh the president has been clear that he
felt the muslim ban
was xenophobic he overturned the muslim
ban
he also though has uh supported um and
he
himself even before or we did i should
say even before he was inaugurated
steps uh travel restrictions in order to
keep the american people safe
she really think we're that stupid or is
she just really not aware that biden was
talking about the covet 19
travel restrictions now tonight at least
one thing has become very clear
and that is the biden administration
does not plan to hold china responsible
for
anything take a look china is engaged in
conduct
that it hurts american workers blunts
our technological edge and threatens our
alliances and our influence in
international
organizations what we've seen over the
last uh
few years is that china's growing more
authoritarian at home
and more assertive abroad and beijing is
now challenging our security prosperity
and values in significant ways that
require
a new u.s approach and this is one of
the reasons as we were talking about a
little bit earlier that
we want to approach this with some
strategic patients
well i guess that's going to make china
great russia great on energy
the middle east they're happy we're
going to get out of the oil and energy
business because they'll be made great
and make a lot of money too
patience for china but not the keystone
xl pipeline clearly
a friendly relationship with the
malignant regime hostile
regime that they are that infected the
world with covet 19
is more important to biden
joe sun zero experience hunter made all
that money
then the thousands of workers by the way
that actually relied
on let's see high paying career jobs in
the energy sector
the keystone pipeline among them to put
food on the table